That was one thing
that really struck
me was the speed at which
the streets became vacant.
Times Square, Abbey
Road, you know,
these are areas that are
always teeming with people.
The Temple Bar area in Dublin.
There's always folks there,
day and night, always.
It's significant, and I've
never seen anything like it,
having this global
network of cameras.
Especially after 9/11,
everywhere in New York
was really quiet.
And it was similar, but
it wasn't to this extent.
And certainly
globally, it wasn't
anything like what
we're experiencing now.
Our purpose is better lives
through visual information.
So what better than giving this
visual information to people
to help them in a time like
this explore the planet,
feel comfort in the fact that
the world is still out there,
we're all going to
get back out there.
You can still go there.
You can still go sit on a beach
virtually and experience things
that you will hopefully be
able to experience very soon
again in real life.
This camera is allowing
us to appreciate
the beauty of the city, but of
course a city without citizen,
it is not a really city.
It's like just a postcard,
something unbelievable,
something amazing, but
something also unreal, no?
Because citizens are
the soul of the city.
And we are a hotel.
So hotel cannot exist without
tourists, especially Venice,
because 90 per cent of the
tourists are also international
tourists.
There is a lot of
uncertainty in town about how
we are supposed to reopen.
Because I think it's quite
difficult to welcome guests
with masks, with temperature
control, and with this disease,
no?
So since lockdown came into
force on the 23rd of March
we've had about 20 times as many
visitors to our webcam's page
that we would expect at
this time of the year.
While we already
know that people
feel happier and healthier when
they're connected with nature,
but at a time like this,
when we're more isolated
from the people that
we're closest to,
spending that time
connecting with wildlife
through the screen
can actually help
to make you feel a lot
better in yourself.
And they're like the most
addictive soap operas, really.
You get to know the characters.
You get to know the individual
badgers, the barn owls,
the puffins... and you just want
to keep going back and getting
to know them even better.
So it can really help soothe
our souls at the moment.
I think the extraordinary thing
that this pandemic has shown
is what once again,
we're all in it together.
This is a global crisis,
as indeed is the climate
and ecological crisis.
Nearly everyone...
we've changed our lives.
You have people who
are frontline workers
in your family, or the people
who are obviously suffering.
But also there are
changes to the lives
which may be for the better.
So for example, you might
actually spend more time
with your family.
You might spend a little
less time commuting.
And indeed, you might
connect more to nature
on your doorstep.
Now all of that qualities,
emotions, and experiences,
which I think somehow we'll need
to capture when we do emerge.
I've kind of akinned
it to a Sunday morning.
I've been working
shifts for 50-odd years,
and Sunday morning's always
that kind of easy, easy time
you could just take
stock and then catch up
a bit of a backlog of things.
Because there's not
much else going on.
And that's what we're seeing
most days at the moment.
Because there's less
traffic as well,
the speeds have
gone up slightly.
Because normally
in central London,
you'd maybe get 5, 10 miles
an hour if you're lucky.
The accidents we're getting
are more serious kind
of damage-wise.
We've got a balcony up on
the seventh floor here.
You go up there for
a cup of coffee,
and you can hear
the birds tweeting,
you can hear the odd
rumble of the odd train.
But that's it.
And that is very peculiar.
This is London.
It shouldn't be like this.
It should be hustle,
bustle, horns, sirens,
everything going off,
trains rumbling past.
A bit un-nerving in a way.
Especially during this crisis,
lots of people from their home
are curious what's going
on in the next city,
or on the opposite
side of the world.
People use it as
a virtual window.
In construction sites saves
the person of the office travel
time, and that will not change
after the crisis is over.
Because they got
accustomed to the fact
that they can watch
remotely, and so no longer
need to be in traffic
for one or two hours.
And we have seen an
increase of requests
for, once this crisis is over,
the regulations will change.
And of course, a theatre
or cinema needs to take
precautions.
One of the precautions now
is instal thermal cameras.
And a thermal camera is because
our body has a temperature, 37
degrees, or 36.5.
You will see the difference
between a sick person
and a not sick person.
We get hundreds of
people watching.
Because they like to watch the
streets, people walking by.
And I guess they look
like they're people
watching, but from their home.
And unfortunately,
obviously, the bars and stuff
are closed in Thailand now.
So we don't really get that
many views through it now.
Because there's nothing
for people to watch.
But the one that's
getting the most attention
now is called Samui
Yacht Club, and it's
like a view of the sea.
Some people write and say
they find it very relaxing.
They put it on in
the background,
and they just like to hear
the sea noise and stuff.